I love the fact that I was really young
going throughout cuz you're just too
dumb to figure I mean I just I would
look I would not want to go through
wheat when I was 24 years old I wouldn't
have wanted to go through boot camp I
mean I would have done it of course but
it would have sucked even more because
you understand the world a little bit a
little bit better you you've had some
kind of a taste of freedom and I mean I
just was like hey okay you want me to do
this I'm gonna do it it was like I was
the perfect recruit really always
because I was just young and dumb so I
suffered some the the biggest thing I
suffered from was just overthinking
stuff because I would sit and why are
they doing this that's the worst thing
that I can ask yourself yeah why it
doesn't matter yeah just do it you have
to learn how to just do and so do this
is one of those things that you need to
learn in your 20s so the what will make
a huge impact is who is telling you what
to do because if you align yourself with
something that you don't believe in with
a person you don't really respect and
they're telling you what to do you're
gonna adapt your life to their way at
that time and the military it's it's got
a very powerful way of creating very
strong people wherever you started you
will end up stronger for your time in
the military and that all begins with
this basic common experience of basic
training and I just I couldn't believe
how how hard it was and how just it was
completely void of all social norms and
etiquettes and all of those things I
mean nothing was off-limits in terms of
their ability to denigrate you for any
reason whatsoever in navy boot camp you
are in open bay barracks obviously and
then the toilets are just on the wall
there's twenty toilets in a row like
you're gonna sit down on the toilet and
then you're gonna be looking at 19 other
people that are also said there's no
privacy whatsoever zero it's all gone
it's just zero and then the other thing
is because this is people always you
know they listen the podcast and they
hey I just didn't listen to Marine Corps
hey just listen the army
they'll send me that message and I'm
like okay 72 hours into boot camp you're
gonna hate me here like just give it
another few more weeks because the thing
that we're not used to even as a 18 year
old is you're not used to your freedom
being completely gone completely there's
zero freedom when you get to boot camp
none zero you're gonna be doing what
someone else tells you to do you have no
freedom to do anything you can't even go
to the bathroom when you want to go to
the bathroom
you throw sergeant can I go use the loo
screen you have unit so freedom
whatsoever and that is as you said very
important lesson to learn on life you
learn to appreciate your freedom and you
also learn to deal with the fact that
hey just because some I can't control
this aspect in my life doesn't mean I
can't control other aspects of my life
and that's an important thing to figure
out as a young person and you kind of
learn to play the game too right like
look there's no way around this this
drill instructor this instructor is
gonna do this and the only possible
thing I can do I mean other than
quitting is just to shut up and just do
what you're supposed to do it's like
okay cool that's no options is a great
option yeah do it or do it or quit and
you can't quit boot camp you can quit
buds or Special Forces qualification
course you can't quit
you're you literally go AWOL and then
they go find you and one guy went AWOL
and they found him at the gas station
you know off base or whatever trying to
get someone to buy him some coffee or
something whatever and they brought him
back and you know then he was back into
it except he was a guy with a bull's-eye
on him because he's the guy that went
AWOL and they dragged him back and it's
it's I can't stress enough what you just
said like you have zero privacy and and
this is a culture shock for a lot of
people because this is the whole
everything that we do our system is
based around a culture of I right at its
basic level now you have your iPhone you
have your individually wrapped
everything you have
you know me me me right and that's gonna
make you happy or that's you know you
everything is is just centered around
the individual and the the army just
doesn't prescribe to that privacy I mean
there's all these privacy debates now
social media and your data and all of
the privacy as if that's just some right
that you have and that's fine there's
there's some nuance to that well let me
just tell you 0% of that exists in the
military zero like you said I mean
there's just a lot of naked dudes you
know with open latrines and and it's
just that's what it is
and you learn that that's kind of a
primordial way to exist and you are much
more in touch with how our species
evolved over our entire evolution of
Homo sapiens when you join the military
and you just become in tune with that
yeah and I think the most important
message that gets relayed into your
brain whether you're conscious of it or
not is crystal-clear and that is this
team and this organization is more
important than you are and your little
wants and needs and desires and your
personality doesn't matter when it's
compared to the needs of this team and
this group and this mission and that's
important another very important thing
to learn as a young person you're not at
the center of the universe period the
end and it's so now as that evolved for
me one of one of the most important
lessons and this is where you have to
spend a lifetime mastering it is to
understand that to be a great teammate
first you have to be a great individual
and then you have to submit to the team
because anybody on your SEAL Teams or my
special forces teams there these are
people that can do anything with their
lives they if they commit themselves
they will do it and so you have to
become a master of your trade a true
professional and in that that requires
the discipline that you have as an
individual when nobody's looking over
your shoulder to just continually
and sharpen sharpen the the blade write
your own and then though you have to
realize that it's not about you it's
it's a it's a balancing act for an
entire lifetime and the more of it the
more that you do both of those in
concert the more rewarding life will be
yeah and really the thing that drives
you to be as good as you can is because
you know your teammates are gonna be
relying on you and if you can't deliver
that's like the worst thing in the world
me being in the SEAL Teams like the
worst thing in the world for someone and
the teams for a good seal is like oh my
teammates were counting on me and I
couldn't deliver for him that's the
that's the lowest of the low hey look
somebody looks at me and says Oh jock
was not that fast or Jocko couldn't do
enough pull-ups or whatever it's like oh
yeah that's on me no big deal but when
they needed me to climb that ladder they
needed me to finish that road march or
move to that position and I couldn't do
it that's that's what always always
drives like a good team guy to be better
it's like they don't want to let their
friends down period it's the ultimate
motivation yeah yeah like to be a part
of that community and in the community
sharpens itself I mean you get guys and
competition competition breeds
excellence they're for sure and so
you've got this world where as iron
sharpens iron so a friend sharpens a
friend and that is just everyday on the
team everything's a competition to
competition